et si mes informations sont bonnes vous
aviez même agi de telle manière qu'un
partenariat soit rompu entre poupé de
Kenza et une firme c'est ça donc elle a
perdu un partenariat je vous incrimine
pas du tout hein mais elle a perdu un
partenariat et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
une ranqueœur mais pour le moment comme
dit maître il y a pas de lien établi
entre cette ranqueur ce contentieux et
l'agression il faut Notter que les
policiers ont pris très au sérieux
l'agression et effectivement ils ont
plusieurs pistes et ils sont décidés à
aller au bout de toutes les pistes avec
notamment la vidéos surveillance et tous
les messages préliminaires qui ont
abouti à ce que son adresse soit
dévoilée oui non moi je su je suis
vraiment évidemment désolé de te voir
dans cet état là de cet état-là et il ne
faut que condamner les agressions dont
tu as été victime j'ai juste une
question à te poser sans aucune
animosité est-ce que ça te fait prendre
conscience du danger du métier que tu
exerces qui est une sorte de journaliste
people 2.0 parce qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes qui te menassent à plusieurs
reprises est-ce que ça te fait peur pour
la suite est-ce que tu dis peut-être que
ce que je fais est un peu trop dangereux
qui peut m'arriver ce genre de chos
encore une fois alors il il y a qu'en
France où il y a cette impunité envers
aquababe c'està dire que alors moi on on
peut tout me faire c'està-dire qu'on
peut me frapper on peut me séquestrer on
peut diffuser des vidéos de moi tout nu
sur internet mais quand il s'agit
d'autre presse c'est-à-dire public
closur ou n'importe ça ça leur fait rien
donc non je comprends pas pourquoi moi
quand il s'agit de moi aquab aniziuni on
a le droit de venir à mon domicile me
séquestrer me frapper non je non je
comprends pas et non j'arrêterai pas mon
métier pour pour ça mais oui au même
titre que Guillaume pareil je je trouve
que c'est terrible ce qui t'est arrivé
et je le remets pas du tout en cause et
cetera mais juste euh bah j'ai bien
compris du coup que tu n'arrêteras pas
de faire ce que tu fais comme travail et
c'est pas du tout méchant ce que je veux
te dire mais est-ce que ça te fait pas
prendre conscience là le cyber
harcèlement que tu dis recevoir est-ce
que ça te fait pas prendre conscience
que tu es aussi des fois euh l'élément
déclencheur de beaucoup
de non mais je je Déon y a des choses
mais non des fois tu dénon son excuse
non bah excuse-moi ma chérie mais à
partir du moment la vérité c'est que tu
as déjà dénoncé des faux des fait me
concernant qui était faux et du coup tu
n'avais pas c'est ta version des fait
après ça reste ta version des fait mais
après on parle de coup k on parle de l'
pour parles de ton pas du tout je parle
pas de moi je veux juste te dire que je
sais mére tu
VO je peux terminer je sais de sources
sûr que des fois tu dénonces des faits
sans savoir s'ils sont véridiques ou non
et c'est ce qui fait de toi selon moi un
journaliste qui est pas forcément très
très bon mais ça excusemoi madame je me
Peret parce que je suis son avocat je
comprends ce que vous dites
concernant hêtement c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui je comprends que vous ayez
eu un contentieux personnel c'est
absolument pas le sujet aujourd'hui
parce que à partir du moment et je vous
fais pas le reproche où vous dites oui
il s'est passé ça mais est-ce que vous
ne pensez pas vous avez pas une espèce
de remise en question un c'est pas le
moment de je crois pas que ce soit le
lieu TR très sincèrement après ce qu'
s'est
passé après ce qu' s'est
passé non mais non mais je comprends et
vraiment je je trouve ça terrible ce qui
lui arrivé j'en suis vraiment navré je
dis juste que effectivement il y a
beaucoup de cyber harcèlement il y a des
gens qui ont vécu des choses dramatiques
à la suite de choses qui ont été dites
et juste est-ce que ça te fait ouvrir
les yeux c'est la seule chose que je
pose comme question et je pense que ce
soit je n'ai jamais cyber harcelé
quelqu'un je sens des articles de presse
je ne suis pas responsable du
cyberhcellement qui est eng engendré
pardon ensuite à la diffusion de mes
articles je ne suis pas responsable je
sors une information comme n'importe
quelle presse sortirait une information
tout simplement et je rajoute qu' ce il
y a pas de procédure mais tuas quand
même il faut dire la réalité on pas au
téléphone à l'époque c'est vrai tu en es
conscient je pense tu as un fond de
commerce qui peut poser des problèmes il
y a des gens qui n'ont pas envie de voir
certains éléments de leur vie privée
dévoilé on n pas à l'esser dans T
les écoutezmo monsieuron que on
n'accepte pas je
suisoc je suis son avocat je suis pas
son premier fan je trouve qu'il fait des
choses parfois bien parfois des choses
moins bien là n'est pas la question je
suis d'accord avec vous peut-être que
vous le réinviterez plus tard quand il y
aura des problèmes sur ce qu'il pourrait
sortir ou pas je dis que dire que ce qui
lui est arrivé peut avoir une certaine
forme de d'influence sur ce qui est son
métier je vous dis attention je vous dit
attention parce que ce n'est pas parce
que il dévoile parfois des information
une conséquence réelle qui est
regrettable évidemment mais c'est une
conséquence pas une conséquence cons oui
mais j'ai une question sur je voudrais
revenir sur sur l'affaire et la violence
parce que les agresseurs étaient trois
c'était prémédité ils avaient donc une
arme de points et un cutterur est-ce que
ils ont été mis en fu parce que aquabb a
eu la présence d'esprit d'appeler son
ami et j'ai vu que vous aviez vous
songiez à élargir l'enquête à tentative
de meurtre donc ma question elle est
est-ce qu'ils étaient venus pour tuer
aquabb écoutez je je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas dans leur fort intérieur pour
l'instant l'enquête elle est ouverte
pour des violences volontaires avec
trois circonstances aggravantes c'est un
délit qui est extrêmement grave qui est
prévu par l'article 222- 13 du code
pénal et qui est qui est punissable de 7
ans d'emprisonnement et 100000 €
d'amende maintenant l'enquête et et on
remise merci les policiers
parceeffectivement il font un gros
travail sur ce dossier il est maintenant
sous protection c'estàdire que il y a un
vrai danger on verra dans l'enquête si
effectivement et j'espère qu'on retrouve
les auteurs qui sont encore en fuite il
y avait une intention de donner la mort
on verra pour l'instant c'est ouvert
pour violence aggravé par trois
circonstances moi si si je puux me
permettre je dans la oui oui c'est quoi
votre r non parce que là là aujourd'hui
on n pas on n pas là pour faire son
procès dis on est là pour parler de
l'agression euh il reviendra une autre
fois on verra voilà mais là c'est c'est
vrai là là les gars vous C vous croyez
où Croz
oùè je pense que rien justifie qu'il se
soit fait agress exactement c'est ça non
mais les mecs rien ne justifie qu'il se
soit fait agresser donc arrêtez avec vos
voilà on en reparlera peut-être une
prochaine fois qu' a dit bien sûr c'est
un jeune homme de 25 ans qui s'est quand
même fait braquer avec une arme de coin
et qui s'est fait là il a la casquette
et voyez voyez le
traumatisme il s'est fait braquer et on
lui a cassé la tête il y a des ITT qui
bah oui on a jamais dit qu'il était
légitime les mec non non mais les mecs
vous pouvez pas lui dire ça je vous dis
vous ne pouvez pas lui dire ça
aujourdhui que vous lu disiez une autre
fois c'est possible maintenant vous
voyez que il est dans un état qui est
difficile
voilà non mais c'est vrai c'est pas
c'est pas le procès
de mec c'est pas parce qu'il a sorti de
trucs sur vous c'est pas parce qu'il a
sorti non non tu peux pas dire ça ni
Guillaume
mer pour lui horrible je pense que c'est
quelqu'un sincèrement qui a du talent
età et je pense qu'il pourrait
l'exploiter autrement et moi je vous le
dis parce que ça m arrivé voilà avant
quand j'tais dans une autre relation en
couple et que j'avais été infidèle voilà
je le dis j'en ai rien à il
voulait sortir des trucs à mon à mon
encontre je lui ai dit vas-y fais-le
mais c'est pas bien et il le sait voilà
c'est dommage de jouer sur ces trucs là
parce qu'on a tous des dossiers on a
tous tous des choses à se reprocher et
avoir ça quand fond de commerce
malheureusement il y a des gens qui vont
mal réagir et qui vont commettre des
agressions ce qui est encore une fois
extrêmement
jus
Pasj ce rien
justif tu fa vraiment et beaucoup de
merde à un moment donné tu réces et tu
fa
agresser sujet
différents
diff
c'est de sujets différents non si au
départ il y a des fake news où il y a
une haine qui part d'un côté rien ne
justifie ce qui lui est arrivé je suis
vraiment moi je ne connaissais pas je
suis vraiment très très désolé mais je
pense que ça fait partie du débat quand
même si je peux vous répondre là-dessus
c'est Monsieur cardose Je me permets en
en répondant comme ça vous êtes déjà les
services de police qui disent c'est
parce que il est aquabab qui s'est fait
agresser c'est parce que il y a eu des
fake news qui se fait agresser vous ne
savez pas n savez rien saz ri
merci merci les chéris il est 20h15 si
vous le savez il faut aller témoignerci
merci d'avoir été avec nous en tout cas
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là et
occuper-vous de votre clientur merci et
on se retrouve dans un instant où on va
on vaà on va enchaîner avec tout ATIS
c'est le débat du jour qui donne le sein
un bébé qui n'est pas le sien et qui
fait scandale re vous choqué à tout de
suite